[Music]
pregnancy is a stressful time for any
expectant mother
that's even more true now because of the
pandemic
pregnant women could be at greater risk
of developing serious side effects from
covet 19 but there's still much
experts don't know about how the virus
affects mothers
and how it's transmitted to babies some
women have been refused medical care or
actively stayed away from hospitals
fearing infection i'm suffering from
covet 19.
i was just diagnosed in la paz hospital
and they refused to treat me
[Music]
birth control and family planning
services have fallen down the list of
health care priorities during the
pandemic
that's meant to search in unplanned
pregnancies
and life-altering decisions for many
young women
the kovid 19 pandemic is creating
unexpected side effects
around the world in malawi a huge spike
in teen
pregnancies is being blamed on
virus-related school closures
human rights organizations say the
government isn't doing enough to protect
the girl's welfare
dw's elson chagara reports
a group of mothers have been making
regular home visits
providing guidance to young girls like
17 year old elisa
she lives alone in a village she fell
for a married man
who promised her a smartphone and food
which turned out to be empty promises
now she is pregnant
when i was in school i used to have a
lot of problems because my family is
poor
i could not have soap body lotion
clothing or food
my mother failed to tend for us children
and so i was having sex and eventually
got pregnant
elisa says she did not know that the man
is married and has two children
unfortunately she never used birth
control
i was aware of family planning methods
but my schoolmates deceived me
they said using contraceptives would
make me unable to have children
so when the man proposed to me we had
sex and he got me pregnant
her outraged parents sent her away
her mother said she could not take care
of erisa and her
we're poor and her pregnancy is an added
burden that i couldn't handle
an ngo in the district has stepped up
its efforts to reduce teenage
pregnancies
it fears more teenage girls could get
pregnant without proper messaging
about family planning and if schools are
not opened soon
we are very saddened with the increased
number of teen pregnancies but
we know that with the collaboration that
we have with different stakeholders we
can
indeed reverse this according to figures
from the national helpline and the
regional department of social welfare
teenage pregnancies in the district have
tripled
one reason is lack of parental care it
seems like
some of them are not taking
responsibility in terms of counseling
and the provision of psychosocial
support to girls and encouraging them
in their education although as of now
our schools
are lost we believe that there could be
disruptions
because the people that are supposed to
be providing these
uh sexually productive health services
for young people are now
occupied to now be able to manage
confidence in cases
if at all they present themselves at the
health center so we're actually thinking
that
there's a disruption of these services
before schools closed it is a worked
hard in class to achieve her dreams of
becoming a teacher
but she remains determined to continue
her education
despite all the obstacles
this isn't the end of my aspirations
after i have the baby
i'll do my best to go back and finish
school
erisa doesn't want to be one of the many
young girls in malawi
who get married before the age of 20.
she has learned her beta lesson and
hopes to bring her dreams
back to life
well let's speak to anita makins from
the international federation of
obstetricians and
gynecologists thanks for joining us what
do we know about the impact that carved
19
is having on unwanted pregnancies
so the i mean it's a very serious
situation the prediction is that about
something like 48 million women won't
have access to
contraceptive methods um and that this
could lead to something between seven
and 15 million unintended pregnancies
worldwide
so you can imagine this will create a
huge burden
to um health systems um
across the world and um and increase the
number of unsafe abortions for sure
this isn't unprecedented there is i mean
you've been researching the effect
of the ebola outbreak in parts of africa
on
family planning what have you learned
from looking at that outbreak
that we can apply now
so when we look at um what happened in
west africa during the ebola africa
during the ebola epidemic um
people stopped accessing health services
and what they considered to be
non-essential and so
antenatal clinic appointments went down
for example in guinea
by about two-thirds um uptake of family
planning methods also went down by about
two-thirds during the epidemic
and then similarly um in liberia by half
by fifty percent
um and um in sierra leone by about a
quarter
um so the impact of that in the long run
uh was then very
very serious and what about in the case
of coronavirus
looking beyond africa where there are
already
problems but what about in higher income
countries
other lower income countries around the
world
yeah so so similarly um our expectation
or what has been happened what we've
been hearing on the grapevine really is
that
um women are trying not to access
uh health services that they can uh
consider non-essential and so
the uptake of contraceptive methods has
has gone down
um the other thing that happened in
high-income countries is that there was
for example in the uk a shift of staff
and closing down services elective
services or services that
were considered non-essential like
sexual health so sexual health clinics
closed down so their staff could go and
work on the covert wards
and gps not seeing people face to face
um doing telemedicine consultations
limited really
and women's access to contraception um
and so we will be seeing the fallout of
that no doubt
um nine months uh from now and we're
talking about
millions potentially of extra births as
a result of this
you know a noticeable increase in the
global population
yeah so so the estimation is between
seven to fifteen million
um unintended extra unintended
pregnancies worldwide
um and obviously uh it'll affect
different countries
different proportions but in in
countries with fragile health systems
that struggle to cope
with the workload they have at the
moment then it's very serious and it'll
set us back
in terms of the progress that has been
made when we look at sustainable
development goals and the
improvements in healthcare that have
been seen in women's health
you know during the millennium
development goals we will be going back
in time with that so
so really really worrying is there
anything being done to
avoid that or at least to mitigate it
uh yeah so so figo the organization i
work for
we've been working very hard we put
together the contraception committee put
together a statement
looking at specific things that could be
done to try to mitigate this
one of the ideas was for example
services which women will continue to
use
for example women coming to give birth
generally
will continue to come to hospital to
give birth
although that's not true all over the
world but certainly in many countries
that would continue to happen so that
these women should then be able to
access
services that they wouldn't be able or
wouldn't want to to use later so
contraception being the main thing so
that actually we should be bringing
contraception contraception services
into maternal healthcare so a lady comes
to have a baby
people talk to her about what
contraceptive methods she she would want
and that she gets that method before she
leaves hospital
um if you use a long acting method like
the postpartum
intrauterine device a little coil or an
implant then you're looking at having
contraception for three to five to even
10 years
and so there isn't a need to keep coming
back to hospital or clinics
so in that sense you know really safe
and a golden opportunity to offer this
health service that otherwise they're
finding hard to access
yeah i suppose it's to some extent about
making the most of those encounters
with these women when they do encounter
uh healthcare workers anita makins from
the
international federation of
obstetricians and gynecologists thanks a
lot for joining us
thank you thanks and now it's time for
one of your questions to our science
correspondent
derek williams this one comes from a
youtube user calling themselves
martian leader one presumably watching
us from afar
[Music]
when will masks no longer be needed
[Music]
this largely theoretical question i
think is worth thinking about even
though there's no
end in sight to the pandemic the issue
of wearing masks has polarized people in
some countries at least
partly due to the fact that despite a
huge amount of
study in the field nobody has been able
to pin down
a concrete number on just how
much they actually help and and how
could studies
reflect the real world anyway i mean
we're all wearing
different kinds of masks often
haphazardly and either abiding by or
not abiding by a lot of different
national rules
there does however now seem to be a
general acceptance by the majority in
most places that that
masks help at least some if they're worn
properly
and in societies like here in germany
where wide scale mask wearing uh was was
unthinkable
just six months ago they're now just a
part of daily life
when you go to the store or when you get
on public transport
the thing is after working so hard to
get people to accept them
i think that governments will be slow to
say that masks are no longer
needed at some point in other words
there's no way to tell
how long we'll need to wear them there's
there's just predicting what has to
happen
before governments are willing to relax
guidelines
and my hunch is that at this point
most governments won't be willing to do
that until
safe and effective vaccines start
keeping
infection rates under control i
personally predict that we'll still be
wearing masks at least
in some settings until at least the
middle of 2021
of course that's one of these cases
where i'd be really happy if my
prediction proved wrong